starting off this hour is sophia in
buffalo new york hi
sophia how are you hi i'm good
how are you better than i deserve how
can we help
so i am about to enter repayment on my
loan
um i made a mistake and went to a
private university
i have about a hundred ten thousand
dollars
mixed between federal and private and
i've already
started putting a couple thousand on it
um
i am a teacher so my income is not great
but i'm ready to go because i'm intense
but i feel like even if i put 100 of my
income
on these loans i won't barely be making
a dent
so i don't really know what to do
what is your income uh sophia about 38
000
yeah so we have the very first thing is
we we got to get a bigger shuffle okay
we have to figure out
how can we get this 38 thousand dollars
up that's the very first
what do you teach i am a kindergarten
teacher right now
okay um are you qualified to teach in
high school
um i'm not qualified for high school but
i am qualified for special ed um and
that usually comes with a pay raise
um for like next year okay
what i was thinking of is what you might
do um tutoring
on the side yes and uh it might be that
there's some special ed families
that would hire you and uh after school
yes that you could do some tutoring or
some special work with some of them
uh maybe give them a little bit of a
breather yeah and have you come in and
teach a little bit
and pay you to do that and that would be
a wonderful extra job
yeah yeah i agree sofia tutor.com is a
great place
too um there's a lot of like um
young people going on there to really
seeking for help and parents right now
with their kids being home
so you can really go in there and
generate probably another 15 to 20
000 in the income if you do that every
day
but right now number one you gotta get
your uh
your income up and then number two i
want you looking to splash financial to
see if they can help you out there
because if not you can possibly
refinance with a much lower interest
rate
if that is an option but basically if we
can find
30 000 a year yep you're done in three
years if you find 25 000
a year you're done in four years
give or take yeah okay and then so this
is doable you're going to get there
yeah but you've got a tough a few years
ahead of you you're going to be working
a lot
not doing anything and working a lot
[Laughter]
but sophia hold on i'm gonna have uh
kelly give you a copy of my destroy your
student loan debt
um i walk through a lot of options on
there to help you speed up the process
uh so stay on the line kelly will get
that for you that's one of our ramsey
quick reads
for those of you that don't know out
there how many pages is that 84
84 pages so it's a couple chapters
basically maybe three chapter book
yep uh that kind of a thing we're doing
a lot of these quick reads dr deloney's
uh book
redefining anxiety is out it's a quick
read it's like 40 or 50 pages or
something and so we're doing a lot of
these that are easy to get through quick
to get through
and the destroying your student loan
debt it is a couple of chapters
and it's really really good you can pick
it up for 10 bucks right now
so it'll help a lot of you and we'll
give you a copy of that sophia and help
you get into this because
basically anthony's right there's what
we call the shovel to hole
ratio you're in a hundred and eight
thousand dollar hole
and you have a 38 000 shovel and he's
saying we need a bigger
shovel so that we can hit on that get
that hole filled up that much
faster